when you did no small affair with demi
moore yes and uh uh before pretty in
pink you you kind of fell in love with
her yeah and uh you guys uh got it on
and
uh you assumed you were her boyfriend
which is such a sad story because i have
been there
and i relate to this because you say hey
you're with demi who's one of the most
beautiful oh my god and charismatic and
funny and just the coolest and it's just
so hot and everything and you're like
wow show business is great i'm in a
movie with this chick and we've we
started making out and we're you know
we're getting into it i love that you
figured out every moment oh my god i
would have been i would have been
intoxicated
but but you assume you're her boyfriend
and then you find out the hard way show
business again is weird because
she has a boyfriend yeah and you've
built up a life with her well i found
out from her housekeeper
because i showed up at her house and i
was like where is she and uh and she and
her housekeeper said she's out with her
boyfriend
and i was like but i'm her boyfriend and
no no no no no no
when that happens do you go up to demi
was it always to me or was it demi it
was always well it's interesting uh it
was to me when i
when i met her but her mom called her
demi uh uh he was her mom's very
southern right uh and uh so i don't know
i don't i don't make the rules so what
did you call her i called her to me
right she wanted to be to me yeah and so
and and here you were having an affair
with her at uh at work et cetera well i
guess if she had a boyfriend you're
right i was having an affair that makes
it hotter
so so here this had been going on for a
while
and and when the housekeeper announces
that hey there's another boyfriend who's
way more known than you you know he's
known as the boyfriend
do you confront her do you go to her and
say wait a second something weird just
happened yes yes yes there was a
confrontation you went to her and and
what did you say well i i was the the
the standard hurt little bunny boy you
know i was like oh i thought we were
serious
you know and and
if i was her i would have been like oh
god
i'm banging you just relax exactly
exactly be happy for a gift and
literally and and that is the that was
the substance of the conversation was
was i did not i did not think we were
exclusive you know and or rather she did
not and i thought we were and i realized
that's because i i was a year out of
high school yeah
you know that was my mindset i was 19 at
the time so did that end the affair was
that that ended the affair we still had
another month to shoot oh how awkward
does that get on a set oh and we had a
love scene to shoot
awkward and awful and do you get like oh
maybe this will reignite the real
because i know what it's like to be in
love and the girls not uh you know
reciprocating is and then isn't it
awkward but you're doing a love scene
with her and you're thinking this will
reignite our romance right no i did not
i did not i was not under that illusion
because if you've seen the film
uh me shirtless is nothing to write home
about
so i did not think that that was the
thing yeah that was going to turn it
around
[Laughter]
and it didn't